[Music]
sometimes it is hard to follow the rules
but when you follow them a little too
much you can actually beat the system
this is how these kids turned out to be
geniuses make sure you watch this video
until the end to know how a kid tried to
train his dog if you love hilarious kids
as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
20 genius kids who beat the system bring
your fish to school day we don't know
why but some teachers decided to
organize the bring your fish to school
day this is why all the parents had to
go to the pet shop to buy a new
companion however one dad didn't really
understand what the teacher meant and he
went to the grocery store instead this
is why the kid was disappointed to see
that he couldn't play with his pet like
all the other students and the smell was
probably terrible anyway don't you think
it is a bad idea to ask kids to buy a
pet that most of them won't even take
care of true or false this kid didn't
even take the time to study or read any
of the questions instead he decided to
work on a plan that would give him the
chance to get the right answer no matter
what the answer is he just found a way
to make the word true look like the word
false or the word false look like the
word true anyway we think that this was
a really smart idea but unfortunately
the teacher didn't fall for this little
trick and he got all the answers wrong
we think we would have got a better
grade simply by writing true everywhere
mathematics is simple who said that
mathematics is hard the only thing you
need is a little imagination to turn a
problem into a solution most students
would be intimidated when they see an
equation like this but this one decided
to keep things simple he didn't see the
word sin but just a bunch of letters
this is why he decided to divide the
letter n by the letter n to turn it into
the number 6 then he just had to add one
and he got 7 he is probably the only kid
in this class who got this answer but
that doesn't mean that he is wrong the
throne just like any mother this mom
asked her son to clean the bathroom that
night and just to make things clear
she said that he should clean it like
the Queen of England is visiting the kid
took things too seriously and decided to
adapt the bathroom to any British person
he added a British flag some greetings
and
everything a British person needs like
some tea to drink and a Harry Potter
book to read on the loom this story
doesn't tell if the Queen of England
really did come to visit but at least
the mother got what she wanted they
should always try this to motivate kids
the chores and here's another kid who
had to do some chores in the bathroom
his mom asked him to pile some toilet
paper on the toilet
however the cat was sleeping there and
the kid didn't let that stop him he
decided to pile the toilet paper on the
cat which is probably funnier than
piling it on the toilet we can't believe
that he managed to make sixteen of them
stay in place on the cat well we
wouldn't want to be him when the cat
wakes up from a nap and he will have to
clean this mess
at least it was fun while it lasted
named the shapes do you want to get in
shape in shape of what during a geometry
test this teacher asked the students to
name the shapes you would expect answers
like square circle or triangle but this
girl decided that those shapes needed a
little more personality she was probably
inspired by her friends because she
decided to name them Jade Charlotte
Charlie Sophia and so on we don't know
what the teachers think yet because the
student hasn't finished her test we
don't think that she will get a good
grade for that but at least her friends
will think that it is really fun and
this is priceless the special drawer
this father decided to hide something
secret in a drawer to keep it away from
children was a candies or money or money
to buy candies he wanted to make sure
that we would never know what was hiding
in there when he put a lock on the
drawer but the kids were smarter than
him when they realized that they just
had to remove the drawer right above it
to get access to what is inside it we
still don't know what it was but no
matter what we think that the kids
deserve to have it for being such
geniuses the Chinese immigrants this
time for homework the kids had to assume
the role of a Chinese immigrant in 1870
and write a letter describing their
experiences but the teacher didn't think
that there was actually a Chinese
immigrant in the room who had taken a
little too seriously
he wrote the whole homework in Chinese
the teacher probably didn't understand
it and neither do we so we don't know if
the student actually said something that
makes sense or if he just copied some
symbols that he saw on the internet no
matter what we think that he deserves a
good grade for the effort can you hang
this out and here's a mom who is asking
us to do some chores again
this time she put a post-it on his shirt
to ask her son if he could hang this out
but the kid took it too seriously when
he decided to hang the posted on the
washing line outside their home we bet
that he was so proud of his prank that
he decided to send a picture to his
mother this was when she answered that
she meant to hang the shirt out of [ __ ]
boy making this joke probably took more
effort than simply hanging out the shirt
but we think that it was totally worth
it the spelling test this time the
teacher asked a pretty simple question
he simply wanted the kids to write 10
words they can spell right but one of
them decided to make things simpler they
decided to write down the words that
were right in front of them 10 words I
can spell right are but don't think he's
done because he actually went for a
challenge right after by writing the
word octopus no matter what the teacher
will have to admit that the student was
right and he would get a good grade we
think that he should even get a bonus
point for that smart answer the
alphabetical order admit it you can't
remember the alphabetical order without
singing the song and there is actually
nothing wrong with that this time a kid
had to write the following words in the
order they came in the alphabet they
just had to put six words in the right
order but this kid decided to make
things much more complicated they put
all the letters in the six words in
alphabetical order to create some
nonsense the teacher has to admit that
it could actually be considered to be a
valid answer but we wish this kid didn't
work that hard for something as simple
as that don't go outside we don't hear
that really often but this time a mother
asked her child not to step outside but
this kid really wanted to enjoy the Sun
in the warm weather this is why he
cheated a little bit by making sure that
his feet would stay inside the home
while the rest of his body is outside
and while he couldn't just move around
on the grass he probably decided to read
a book or play a game on his tablet
instead we think that this young boy was
born to be a lawyer because no one can
argue with him he really did not step
outside not your father's ginger ale
when her father asked this girl to give
him his ginger ale she just couldn't
find it there was actually a bottle of
ginger ale on the counter but you could
clearly read that it was not her
father's ginger ale it just seems
impossible that it could ever be his
anyway we were pretty sure that this
girl was looking for an excuse not to
make any effort at least her father
probably laughed at this joke and
has the energy to stand up and pick it
up by himself after all he is probably
the only one who inspired her to make
this dad joke
the KFC experience Kentucky Fried
Chicken would do anything to get more
followers on social media this time they
asked their customers to go online to
share photos videos and tweets of their
KFC experience we are seriously
wondering what we are supposed to do
should we post a video of ourselves
eating or maybe post an Instagram
picture of our not so good-looking meal
no matter what this kid followed the
rule and took his cell phone to post a
picture online there is really nothing
else you can do to share your KFC
experience surprisingly he really did
get more attention than what he expected
no shorts no matter how warm it was
outside this school decided to ban
shorts because was not part of the
uniform it looks like this kids teachers
really don't know what he is going
through and it seems unfair that girls
still have the right to wear skirts this
is why he decided that he was going to
wear a skirt too after all it is part of
the uniform so the teachers can't say
anything about this this guy probably
got a lot of attention from his friends
who were jealous maybe he will only
start a new trend Happy Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving is a time when all the
family is supposed to spend time
together but unfortunately the oldest
brother was working that night this is
why he asked his little brother to save
some food for him and he did really save
a little bit of everything he just
forgot to say that it was really a tiny
little bit of everything it was so small
that it was hard to know what it was so
he even took the time to write down what
it was what a caring little brother but
we are pretty sure that it was just a
joke and he actually did save a whole
plate for his brother the future
journalist when you are in school you
get the chance to explore many different
jobs to know what you will be doing
later when you grow up this time the
kids were going to learn how to write an
article they had to write a title and
the student decided to name it how
chicks grow then he was asked what this
article was about and he's simply
answered how chicks grow what a stupid
question you can guess it by looking at
the title we have to admit that
professional writers don't write down
the answers to that question anymore but
it is still a good idea to know what you
are going to write about wash your hands
before dinner
no matter how many times our mother
asked us to wash our hands before dinner
we are not doing it now that we are
grownups unless we touched something
weird but
this kid was too young for this so his
mom had to ask him to go to the
restaurants bathroom and clean his hands
there were even some instructions to
tell him how to do it properly you just
have to run the water put the soap in
the sink and make sure you don't touch
anything his mother won't be proud of
him but what she doesn't know can't hurt
her the snack there are some very strict
rules in this house this young boy is
not allowed to use his tablet in the
kitchen and he's not allowed to eat in
the living room so what can he do if he
wants to eat a snack while watching a
video on his tablet this young boy had
the chance to get the best of both
worlds by lying in the middle of the two
rooms he must be really proud of himself
because there's nothing his mom can do
against this he is still following the
rules we think that this boy will go
really far the dog trainer we all know
that kids want to get a dog and then
they never take care of them but this
time this mom asked her son to train the
dog and told him to watch videos on
YouTube to know what to do however he
didn't just use the video as an
inspiration he just showed the video to
the dog hoping that he would understand
what he should do what we see here is
either a really naive boy or a really
smart dog who was your favorite kid on
this list don't be shy to answer in the
comments section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for 20
genius kids who feed the system for more
stories like this make sure you watch 20
toys no kid wants to receive on their
birthday thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]